.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ich bin Simone.
- Ich bin Michi.
In ca. zwei, drei Wochen
werden wir zum ersten Mal Eltern.
Ich habe mich
mit dem Coronavirus infiziert.
Mein Name ist Daniel Eberli.
Wir sind wegen Corona
in Norwegen gestrandet.
Ich bin Sandra Kissling.
- Ich bin Dennis Kissling.
Wir sind im Moment zu Hause.
Ich habe ein Bestattungsunternehmen.
Wegen des Coronavirus
habe ich viel mehr zu tun.
* Ruhige, melancholische Melodie,
Stimmengewirr *
So ...
Das ist
mein doch schon grosser Babybauch.
Ich sehe zwar meine Füsse noch,
zum Glück.
Wie erwähnt bin ich
in der 38. Schwangerschaftswoche.
Was bedeutet, dass es
nicht mehr allzu lange dauern wird,
bis wir eine kleine Familie sind.
Ja ...
Vor einer guten Woche
haben wir geheiratet.- Mhm.
Relativ spät in der Schwangerschaft.
Wir haben uns spontan
dazu entschieden, wirklich spontan.
Es wurde ein sehr surrealer,
skurriler, lustiger Tag.- Mhm.
* Entspannter Swing-Song *
* Einzelner Jubelruf *
Das Komische an ...
... dieser Virusinfektion ist, dass
jeden Tag etwas Neues dazukommt.
Gestern waren es ...
... Gliederschmerzen
und ein allgemeines Unwohlsein.
Heute ist es ...
Ich habe das Gefühl, eine wahnsinnig
starke Erkältung zu haben.
Nicht ... besonders angenehm.
Das Problem ist ...
Ich versuche,
eine Spaghettisauce zu kochen.
Es ist einfach ...
Ich schmecke nichts.
Rein gar nichts.
Das ist angeblich
eine der vielen Nebenwirkungen
oder Symptome des Coronavirus:
Man schmeckt nichts, weder Zwiebeln,
noch Knoblauch, noch Fleisch.
Egal.
Es ist Tag 3 des Lockdown.
Auch mein Leben
hat sich total verändert.
Normalerweise würde ich zum Tram
gehen und zur Arbeit fahren.
Aber das geht nicht -
ich nehme das Velo.
Es ist die sicherste Methode,
um sich nicht anzustecken.
Als Arzt
ist Daniel Eberli in Bereitschaft.
Das Zürcher Unispital
wappnet sich Mitte März
für den Ansturm
von schwer kranken Corona-Patienten.
Normalerweise würde ich so arbeiten.
In der Krise arbeite ich eher so,
damit man alles wechseln kann.
Und immer genug Alkohol
auf die Hände.
Das Unispital nahm die Weisungen
des Bundesrates
und der Gesundheitsdirektion
sofort sehr ernst.
Auf der Urologie fuhren wir
alles runter, was möglich war,
um diese Räumlichkeiten zur kleinen
Intensivstation umzubauen.
Die Ruhe im Unispital
ist momentan fast gespenstisch.
Wir sind bereit, falls der Ansturm
tatsächlich noch kommt.
Mathematisch müsste er kommen.
Die Kollegen
der Notfall- und Intensivmedizin
arbeiten jetzt schon an Fällen.
Als Urologe bin ich
bereit zu helfen, wo ich kann.
Wir müssen momentan
noch nichts aktiv unternehmen.
* Er lacht. *
Geschmacklich einfach nichts -
ich könnte ebenso gut
Spaghetti ohne Sauce essen.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich gut gekocht habe.
Wenn es ungeniessbar ist,
müssen wir es einfach essen,
bevor wir es merken.
Ich habe neulich gelesen,
dass das mit dem Geruchssinn
e h e r  am Ende
der Erkrankung kommt.
Das ist zwar nicht lustig,
gibt aber etwas Hoffnung.
Das ist alles sehr beunruhigend.
Denn man weiss nicht, wie ...
... der Verlauf
bei einem aussehen wird.
Dann schauen wir
die Fotos der Hochzeit an,
wenn wir uns
schon nicht sehen können.
Sehr schön.
- Okay?
Es war niemand da.
- Die Leute, die nicht da waren,
schickten wir weg.
Händehygiene, logischerweise.
Social Distancing.
Die Corona-Krise
hat insofern dazu beigetragen:
Wenn uns etwas passieren würde,
mit der Geburt und Corona ...
Die Chance ist etwas erhöht,
dass jemand auf die Intensiv kommt.
Das hat vielleicht
schon noch den ...
... gewissen Anstoss gegeben,
das ganz durchzuziehen.
Guten Morgen.
Es ist Zeit,
das Innere unseres -
wie sagt man? - Autos zu zeigen.
Hier haben wir
die letzten Tage geschlafen.
Ziemlich komfortabel - in Zukunft
würde ich es noch etwas ausbauen.
Etwas Wasser für die Fahrt.
WC-Papier, natürlich.
Davon haben heutzutage alle genug.
* Leises Lachen *
Hinter diesem Vorhang
ist nur WC-Papier.
Ja, wir haben
nur WC-Papier mitgenommen.
Aus Angst, dass man es
in der Schweiz nicht kriegt.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge,
Gesang *
Camilla und Louis, auf dem Weg
zurück in die Schweiz - unplanmässig.
Die Corona-Krise bedeutet das jähe
Ende ihrer Skandinavien-Reise.
Sie befanden sich in Norwegen,
als das Land den Lockdown anordnet
und dicht macht.
Keine Flüge, chaotische Verbindungen.
In ihrer Not
kaufen die beiden ein Auto.
Ein Auto zu kaufen und zu gehen,
haben wir entschieden,
weil es in Norwegen
nicht mehr lustig war.
Wir fanden keine Hotels mehr.
Wir haben auch SMS erhalten,
wir sollen das Land verlassen.
Das können wir vorlesen.
"Wichtige Mitteilung
der örtlichen Behörde:
Die Gefahrenabwehr ist aufgrund
des Coronavirus unter Druck."
"Bitte beenden Sie Ihren Urlaub."
Obwohl sie uns draussen
haben wollten, half niemand.
Sie hätten Anweisungen geben müssen,
wie man am besten
von den Lofoten wegkommt.
Wir meldeten uns immer wieder
bei Konsulaten oder Botschaften.
Am Schluss hiess es,
es sei eine Krisensituation,
niemand habe einen Überblick.
Die Verantwortung, nach Hause
zu kommen, liege aber bei uns.
Allgemein fällt mir auf,
wenn ich mal allein unterwegs bin,
dass mir immer mehr Dinge fehlen.
Dinge, die ich mochte,
die mir wichtig waren.
Bei mir ist es nur -
es ist vielleicht doof -
zwischendurch abschalten
und in einer Brockenstube wühlen,
um zu schauen,
ob man einen Goldschatz findet.
Sandra Kissling
rettet Lebensmittel vor dem Müll.
Weil Gastrobetriebe aufgrund
der Corona-Krise geschlossen sind,
bleiben Händler und Lieferanten
auf ihrer Ware sitzen.
Schwierige Zeiten,
auch für Gemüsebauern.
Krautstiele, ganz frisch.
Frischer geht's nicht: Die wurden
gerade geschnitten, wunderschön.
Aber das würde im Moment
alles liegen bleiben.
Es ist von einem Gemüsebauern,
der sonst auf dem Markt verkauft.
Statt im Abfall landen Spinat und
Krautstil in Sandra Kisslings Laden,
zu günstigeren Preisen.
Gut, angekommen beim Laden.
Wir haben Kunden.
Hier haben wir auch ...
... Hände desinfizieren.
Wir sind ein kleiner Laden
in der Altstadt.
Am Boden
sind unsere Abstandsstriche.
Am Morgen
messe ich als Erstes Fieber.
Das hat sich so ...
... eingebürgert.
Das ist sehr gut,
das Fieber ist endlich weg.
Keine Ahnung, ob ich
noch ansteckend bin oder nicht.
Deshalb bleibe ich lieber zu Hause.
Gott sei Dank
haben wir einen Garten.
Der hilft, wenn einem
die Decke auf den Kopf fällt.
Man kann einfach raus.
Heute ist es zwar arschkalt.
Aber es tut trotzdem gut,
rauszukönnen, im Garten rumzugehen.
Das bringt einen
auf andere Gedanken.
Zuerst kam die Meldung,
alles werde runtergefahren.
Damals dachte ich auch:
"Schön, alles etwas ruhiger."
"Klingt schön,
etwas runterzuschrauben."
Dann dauerte es 1 1/2 Std.
und mir wurde bewusst,
und ich hörte
die Reaktionen per Telefon,
dass es lebensmitteltechnisch,
für den Bereich, in dem ich arbeite,
das Gegenteil
von Runterschrauben ist.
Dass es jetzt
vollen Einsatz braucht.
Es kommen massenweise Produkte.
Ja, das ganze Paket.
Familie ...
Das Geschäft, Homeschooling ...
Es ist schwierig,
alles unter einen Hut zu bringen.
* Die Kinder schreien. *
Charleen!
Au!
* Weinen *
Arschloch!
Die Älteren
sind eben stärker und grösser.
Entschuldigung, Filou. ??
Wenn die Fernbedienung kaputtgeht,
könnt ihr nicht mehr fernsehen.
(Rufend) Charleen, wo bist du jetzt?
Bitte!
Ach, da. Gut.
Mein Sohn macht Chaos mit Kleister.
Aber gut, lassen wir ihn.
Hauptsache,
ich könnte mal die Anrufe erledigen.
Sieht toll aus in unserer Wohnung.
Wir sitzen zu Hause,
gehen nicht raus.
Eigentlich sollte ich
mit Charleen Homeschooling machen.
Den Berg Wäsche sieht man hier auch.
* Fernseher im Hintergrund *
Wir haben
mit Homeschooling begonnen,
oder es versucht.
Es ist ... eskaliert.
Es war wirklich nicht möglich.
Zwei Kinder im Kindergartenalter
und in der ersten Klasse ...
Dazu läutete das Telefon.
Damit ich arbeiten konnte, habe ich
den Kindern den TV eingeschaltet.
* Rockiger, hoher Gesang *
Louis und Camilla
nach drei Tagen nonstop im Auto.
Noch drei Tage bis zum vollen ...
* Louis mault rum. *
... Verstandesverlust.
Mh!
Pasta mit Tomatensauce!
Oh.
- Was?
Ehrlich, gefroren?
Scheisse.
Es ist immer kalt hier.
So kalt ist es doch gar nicht mehr.
Schon 5 °C.
Ich wollte den Deckel auf die Pasta
legen, dann fiel alles zu Boden.
Was machst denn du?
- Der hat nicht gehalten.
Am Morgen
ist man müde und verdrückt,
dann steigt die Moral stetig.
Am Nachmittag
wollen wir gar nicht mehr heim.
Am Abend ... ist schon wieder ...
Dann denken wir: "Scheisse,
wir wollen zu Hause sein."
Wir sehen Michi,
wie er unsere mobile Rudermaschine
zu unseren lieben Nachbarn bringt.
Genau, wir machen
den kürzesten Lieferservice,
den Zürich je sah.
Das gehört zum typischen
Nestbauverhalten einer Schwangeren.
Nein, ich weiss nicht.
Ich kann sie nicht davon abhalten,
alles auf Hochglanz zu polieren.
Ich versuche sie zu unterstützen,
wo ich kann.
Vieles will sie selbst machen.
Ich glaube,
das hat mit Corona nichts zu tun.
Und doch: Das Virus hat Einfluss
auf die Situation werdender Eltern.
In den Spitälern und Praxen
dürfen Väter zwar bei der Geburt,
nicht aber beim Wochenbett oder
den Voruntersuchungen dabei sein.
Am Wochenende, vor einigen Tagen,
hatte ich diesbezüglich
eine ziemliche Krise.
Wegen der ganzen Fremdbestimmtheit,
die dadurch herrscht.
Ich gehe in den Kämpfermodus.
Ich sagte, dass wir
sonst eine Hausgeburt machen.
Michi nennt es Piratengeburt.
Wir werden sehen,
ob es darauf hinausläuft.
Wenn sie wirklich
alles einschränken, schauen wir,
ob das Kind in unseren eigenen
vier Wänden zur Welt kommt.
Ich bin unterwegs,
es ist Montagmorgen.
Ich soll an einer Trauerfeier
eine Trauerrede halten.
Es ist etwas schwierig, weil
die Familie Abstand halten muss -
dazu bin ich verpflichtet.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es ist,
vor dieser kleinen Gruppe
eine Trauerrede zu halten.
Es wollten
ja eigentlich viele kommen.
* Kirchenglocken *
Die Glocken
läuten für die Trauerfeier.
Die Angehörigen haben mir erlaubt,
das zu filmen.
Wir sehen, diese Familie
muss viel Abstand halten.
Das ist eigentlich traurig.
Es berührt mich gerade sehr.
Sonst wären wohl 60-70 Personen
an dieser Beerdigung.
Aber nur das ist bewilligt.
Für mich
war es eindrücklich und erstaunlich,
wie streng und gut
sie die Empfehlungen einhielten.
Aber es war unglaublich traurig.
Nach der Aufzeichnung des Videos
im Friedhof Bremgarten
liefen mir Tränen runter.
Sie taten mir so leid.
Eine so liebe Familie,
mit sonst grossem Zusammenhalt.
Und sie haben sich
so an die Regeln gehalten.
Das hat mich ...
Das hat mich belastet.
Das hat mich emotional belastet.
Okay, Schere, bitte.
Das ist perfekt.
Wir haben aktuell ein Verbot
für elektive Eingriffe.
Es gibt aber welche,
die man durchführen muss, wie hier.
Tumore wachsen schnell,
da muss man vorwärtsmachen,
sonst hat der Patient
einen Nachteil.
Ich wollte Sie sprechen, weil wir
Ihre Operation verschieben mussten.
Ich habe Ihre Kenndaten der
Tumorbiologie noch mal angeschaut.
Ich mache mir
keine Sorgen um Sie momentan.
Das muss man
nicht notfallmässig durchdrücken.
Für mich ist es
eine zusätzliche Belastung.
Ich hatte es
ehrlich gesagt etwas unterschätzt.
Ich meinte,
dass es an mir abprallen würde.
Im Sinn von: Ich bin ein Profi,
gehe damit einfach um.
Wir müssen
viele Patienten beruhigen,
viele Anrufe tätigen.
Es sind viele Ängste vorhanden,
z.T. gerechtfertigt,
z.T. eher nicht - usw.
19.
- Ja.
Gibt vier.
- Bravo.
(Mann) Rechnet ihr gern?
- (Beide) Ja.
Verdammt fest.
- Echt?
Was macht ihr sonst noch gern?
Ausser Rechnen ...
- Am liebsten Pause.
* Lachen *
Sandra Kisslings Mann Dennis
beim Homeschooling mit den Kindern.
Aufgrund der Doppelbelastung
haben die Eltern Arbeit und Familie
nun klar aufgeteilt.
Ich musste mich dagegen entscheiden,
zu Hause zu sein, sonst ...
Wir wären beide nur noch ...
- ... hinterhergerannt.
... durchgedreht
und hätten einander angeschrien.
Die Kinder auch,
die gar nichts
für diese Situation können.
Mittlerweile
sind alle Symptome verschwunden.
Ich wage es nun, rauszugehen -
nach zehn Tagen.
Ein seltsames Gefühl.
Ich werde logischerweise
noch Abstand halten.
Aber ich
muss jetzt einfach etwas raus,
sonst fällt mir
die Decke auf den Kopf.
Es ist niemand unterwegs,
weit und breit niemand.
Es ist wie
in einer Zombie-Apokalypse,
in einem Hollywoodfilm -
sehr seltsam.
Andererseits ist es auch
ein gutes Gefühl, rauszukönnen.
* Tuten *
Auf ihrer Rückreise in die Heimat
durchqueren Camilla und Louis
Schweden.
Das war verdammt knapp.
Krass, da kann man noch Ski fahren.
Während die Schweiz stillsteht, geht
hier das öffentliche Leben weiter.
Schau mal, die sitzen zusammen
auf der Terrasse.
Gibt's ja nicht -
in der heutigen Welt.
Kaffee.
- Mh, sieht gut aus.
Die Schweden haben schon Recht.
Guten Tag, Frau Weber. Hier Jenni.
Guten Tag. Ich habe eine Frage dazu,
wie es abläuft,
wenn man ein Fahrzeug aus
dem Ausland in die Schweiz einführt.
Wir sind immer noch in Schweden.
Meine Frage ist:
Falls wir es
zurück in die Schweiz schaffen,
dürfen wir nach Zürich fahren
oder müssen wir es
erst am Zoll deklarieren?
Dürfen wir mit dem norwegischen
Nummernschild nach Hause fahren?
Ich weiss gar nicht genau,
was die Schweizer Regelung ist,
wenn man aus dem Ausland heimkommt.
Aber ich würde mich
mal zwei Wochen verschanzen.
Auch für mein Umfeld.
Und dann weiterschauen.
Ich habe Mühe damit,
nach Hause zu kommen
und niemanden umarmen zu dürfen -
verdammt komisch.
Wir haben viel Material geladen
für die Grosseltern.
Die Kinder haben gezeichnet.
Du kannst deinen Bruder fragen,
was er zum Ganzen meint.
Was sagst du zum ganzen Corona?
Fuck you, Corona.
Und ich finde es doof, dass man
nicht mehr zu den Grosseltern darf.
(Alle) Hallo!
Maxim, du darfst nicht zu nahe ran.
Von hier kannst du reden.
Gebt ihnen das doch beim Fenster.
Ihr könnt ja nicht raufspucken. Und
für uns ist es ja nicht gefährlich.
Du musst es noch desinfizieren!
- Ja, sollte ich.
Anfangs fühlte es sich schön an,
sie zu schützen.
Jetzt fehlt mir einfach -
oder wohl uns allen -
der Sonntagabend,
an dem wir sonst immer dort sind.
Es fehlt mir sehr.
Es ist wirklich sehr schwierig
für uns.
Es ist einfach
etwas weniger Leben im Haus.
Ja, etwas langweilig.
Ich gehe jetzt ins Wohnzimmer
und will später
mit meiner Frau fernsehen.
Wir wollen "Mini Schwiiz,
dini Schwiiz" schauen.
Sie putzt zwar gerade noch etwas.
Dann setzen wir uns und schauen es.
(Alain Berset)
Nein, aber es wird lang dauern.
Wir müssen ehrlich sein ...
Wie soll ich es sagen?
Es ist wie ein unbekannter Feind.
Es ist etwas hier,
das man nicht sieht.
Man weiss nicht,
was man eigentlich machen sollte.
Ausser man glaubt einfach,
was sie sagen und hält sich daran.
Nach dieser Sendung gehe ich kochen.
Prost.
- Genau, prost.
Sie werden verschraubt
und mit Bostitchen versehen,
damit sie stabil sind.
Es ist massives Tannenholz.
Dann müssen sie
ausplastifiziert werden.
Wieso, weiss ich auch nicht genau.
Wohl, weil Flüssigkeiten
auslaufen könnten.
Bei meinen Särgen
mache ich das nicht.
Bestatter Beni Hochuli
hat einen offiziellen Auftrag:
die Herstellung von Spezialsärgen
auf Vorrat.
Holzkiste um Holzkiste stapelt sich
abholbereit in der Garage.
Natürlich: Bei solchen Anlässen -
oder Vorkommnissen -
stockt man schon etwas auf.
Entschuldigung, ich musste etwas
werfen, die Kinder sind etwas laut.
* Kinderlachen *
Ähm - wo waren wir? Sorry.
Gleich Hunderte Särge
ans Lager nehmen,
Hunderte Leichensäcke oder so ...
Das wäre schon übertrieben.
So weit sind wir
in der Schweiz nicht.
Die Massnahmen sollten
Derartiges wirklich verhindern.
"Vor ihrer Abwesenheit
hat er nicht da gestanden,
davon ist sie überzeugt."
Das Problem ist:
Im Moment
fallen ziemlich viele Lesungen weg.
Fast alle, bis April/Mai.
Das ist viel Einkommen,
das einfach flöten geht.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Ich weiss nicht, ob Internetlesungen
wirklich etwas bringen.
Aber im Moment
habe ich nicht viel anderes zu tun.
Es ist eine Möglichkeit,
sich bemerkbar zu machen.
Wir sind auf dem Weg
ins Geburtshaus.
Es könnte sein, dass es losgeht.
Heute war der Blasensprung.
Wir gehen schauen,
was die Hebamme dazu sagt.
Sehr schade finde ich,
dass Michi nicht hochkommen darf.
Die Zahl der Todesopfer
infolge einer Corona-Infektion
in der Schweiz
stieg ebenfalls von 378 auf 432.
Simone war gerade im Untersuch.
Wir hatten per FaceTime Kontakt.
Ich konnte zuschauen
und hörte, was die Hebamme sagte.
Immerhin - besser als nichts.
Hallo.
- Hoi.
Und, wie war's?
- Ja ... Schade, warst du nicht da.
Ähm ... Gut.
In den nächsten 40 Std. geht es los.
* Entspannte Ukuleleklänge *
Verdammt viele Lastwagen.
Das ist sicher wegen dem Zoll.
Krass,
müssen die alle kontrolliert werden?
Scheisse - ich würde nicht
durch die Schweiz fahren.
Es sind die einzigen,
die am Zoll kontrolliert werden.
Das nervt ja wahnsinnig.
- Scheisse.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
was jetzt kommt.
Nach sechstägiger Reise
kommen Camilla und Louis
an der Schweizer Grenze an.
Noch ist unklar,
ob sie den Grenzübergang
mit dem in Norwegen gekauften Auto
ohne Weiteres passieren dürfen.
* Jubelschreie *
Wir haben es geschafft!
Krass! Wir dachten es
schon nicht von Anfang an.
Es war uns nicht so wohl.
- Nein, auch die Beamten rätselten.
Keiner von ihnen
hat je ein Auto von Norwegen ...
Wir haben es geschafft.
Nicht mehr weit.
Meine Fresse.
Schau, wir sind in der Schweiz.
Die Schweiz.
Jetzt müssen wir
mal jemandem schreiben oder anrufen.
So, wir sind in unserer Bubble
angekommen.- Baby-Bubble.
Uns geht es sehr gut,
wir sind seit zwei Tagen zu Hause.
Ich bin gesund, der Kleine auch.
Immerhin konnte ich dabei sein
und bleiben, darüber bin ich froh.
Uns tut es sogar gut ...
Die ganze
von aussen gemachte Distanz.
Dadurch haben wir nicht das Gefühl,
wir müssen viele Leute einladen.
So können wir zu dritt gut ankommen.
Das tut uns sehr gut.
* Entspannte Jazzklänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Meret Hachen - 2020